[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
be a subscriber like and comment
hey guys during the penultimate episode
of the show Danny Targaryen burned down
entire King's Landing street-by-street
killing all the innocent as well as
their own people as Cersei Lannister
watched from the red keep the one
Saviour of Westeros has become the meth
Queen well what if I tell you that's not
true what if I tell you it wasn't Danny
who burned down King's Landing but it
was rather brain stark who worked into a
dragon and burned the capital think
about it after the bells after the city
has surrendered we do see Danny angry
but her focus is not on the innocent in
their houses but on Cersei and red keep
then he flies her dragon towards it and
then just as his Sebring's vision of a
shadow of a general flying above King's
Landing
juergen all the sudden changes his
direction and starts burning down all
the innocent I think it was made clear
that Dany was heading towards the red
cape and never intended to burn King's
Landing
I believe it's brain who worked into her
dragon change the course and burned
everything and everyone
Danny was intending to just fly to the
red cape but brain worked into Jovan and
start the killing after showing Danny
angry heading for the red cape to kill
Cersei they never show her again just
jog on destroying the city why is that
why do we never see Danny on the dragon
once the killing starts what if she was
freaking out wondering why dragon was
killing everything what if instead of
their needs bran who is the final
villain of the story by controlling her
dragon and burning down the entire
King's Landing and all the innocent
brand may Danny the scapegoat and Jeff
thinking she's gone fully mad we'll kill
her
well spend the last episode thinking
Danny's a terrible person this mate
queen watch her get assassinated and
feel everything is justified
well John take the black and go on the
wall for killing her and sing brains
start democratically chosen as the next
king on the throne then we find out that
the Lord of Light has been manipulating
everything all the major players were
manipulated the entire show to reach
this result
John is really a fire white brought back
to life by the Lord of Light to kill
Danny we have our final winner in the
Game of Thrones the Lord of Light brain
stark could it be the final twist of the
series this has always been again and
who better than bran playing the game
better than any
else it's going to be John who kills
Danny that's why he was resurrected and
bran will sit on the ash throne and
become the king of ashes
the pressing question many of us were
asking after the bells the fifth episode
of the final season was just simply what
in the seven hells was brain start doing
during Danny's massive and sudden death
queen he'll turn what good is having an
all-knowing and all-seeing three-eyed
Raven if he was not there to prevent
this or just do anything during this war
well in this theory that question is
answered as his the one who burned down
the Capitol there's been a lot of
speculation regarding Prince ultimate
role in the game of Thrones but everyone
is in agreement that he is going to play
a major part in the story's finale some
people are convinced he is going to
become the knight King while others
believe he could be the Lord of Light
and flash as this theory suggests a lot
has happened since season one and
everything has been leading up to a
climactic event the demise of King's
Landing the series then has been
foretold in visions and bran might be
the one pulling all the strings
everything we need to know has already
been shown to us we've already seen the
demise of King's Landing before it
happened and not once but on two
separate occasions in the series then a
first witnesses the set is falling the
final episode of season 2 when she has a
vision of a royal red cape covered in
ashes brandy has also visions of the red
cape but its roof burned down and ashes
falling on the Iron Throne and we'll see
that vision in the final episode perhaps
in a scene her brain enters red keep
after Dan is being killed by John Snow
and John took the black and brain
becomes the king in another vision he
sees the shadow of a dragon flying over
King's Landing the one that came true in
the last episode it's also interesting
how brain sees King's Landing from
John's perspective I really believe it
was him who worked into joggin anyways
another thing we see in Ren's vision is
the caches of fire that are contained
beneath the city Cersei already used
some of them to decimate the Sept of
Baelor this massive store saw green
flames for now the key to defeating the
White Walkers but it still play a huge
role in completely destroying the
capital the Mad King has burned them all
phrase is very much repeated to our
brains visions King Aerys ii is heavily
featured in brains virile visions
repeating his famous last words of
burned them all there are some
speculations which suggests bran himself
might be responsible for the mad Kings
madness maybe he already tried to burn
down the Capitol with Mad King but
failed and now he's managed to do it
with his daughter Danny by using her
dragon the show's creator said the most
important of brands visions is a share
of a dragon flying over King's Landing
in age Bill's inside the episode for
season 4 episode 2 there's a very
interesting interview with writers about
brains visions dby is the co-creator of
the series talks about how each vision
that brain sees is directly related to
his journey right after death co-creator
David Benioff says this may be the most
crucial shot to us was the shadow of a
dragon flying over King's Landing
why sing the shadow of danger a gun from
Episode five just before she burns down
the capital so crucial for brain and how
is it directly related to his journey
one would wonder well if that's the
moment when brain works in the Geoghan
and sees his own shadow and burns down
the entire King's Landing then yeah it's
pretty important for brain in his
journey as a powerful skin-changer bran
Stark definitely is able to control the
image dragon the three-eyed Raven tells
brain that he will never walk again but
he will fly did we just see that come
true in the last episode the three
demons past and present have never been
known for speaking clearly so this
statement is open for interpretation
maybe he meant that brain will fly in a
figurative sense by transcending his
physical limitations maybe he meant that
brain would fly through time which we've
seen him do maybe he meant brain would
work in two birds another case in which
the prophecy would already have been
fulfilled even FL
where we left him last season brain was
working in total to track the night king
and he's also done it multiple times for
the season eight alternatively of course
the three Raven couldn't man brain would
work into a dragon is there any evidence
that anyone has ever worked into a
dragon
in short no the closest they can come is
a mysterious quote from Tyrion in the
dancer dragons about the Valyrians
reluctance to visit Westeros the
freehold grasp has reached as far as
Dragonstone but never to the mainland of
Westeros itself odd that Journal stone
is no more than rock the belt was father
vest but they had dragons surely they
knew he was there one of the many
possible implication is the development
state clear of the mainland and they can
the Conqueror did not conquer anything
of the wall because they were worried
about the powerful first man working
into their dragons during a more magic
rich age most key changers can only work
in two small animals but brains the most
powerful skin-changer not only did he
work into all different kinds of animals
from daryl's to Ramon's but he also
managed to work into human into horror
multiple times
that's why Jojen and Meera Reed were so
stunned the first time brain worked into
horror most works can enter the minds
only of animals as brains powers grew
stronger he's definitely able to wear
down a dragon's resistance as War Amir
the experienced work once said once the
course is broken to the saddle any man
can mount him
once the beasts been joined to a man any
skin-changer can sleep inside and ride
him long ago way back in july of 2011
when the dance of dragons was newly
released martin fielded a fan question
about whether Jagan's forwardable he
chuckled and said well we'll have to see
about that won't we in the bogus George
Intel's branded he had green dream about
the winged bull bound to earth with
great stone chains a three-eyed crow was
trying to peck through the chains but a
stone was too hard and his Baek could
only chip at them George explains that
brain is the chain ring wolf and the
crows send the reeds to break his chains
this is obviously the future he saw he
had greenside the power of prophetic
green dreams he also says that brain
breaks the chain and flies
now since green seer dreams have been
mentioned to be a mix up of things it
still told us that brain was destined to
eventually warga dragon and I believe he
just did I believe brain work in two
Danish dragon and burn down King's
Landing
while all Danny could do was watch in
horror unable to control him brain made
Danny the scapegoat and Jean thinking
she's got fully manual killer before she
gets a chance to explain she was not the
one controlling Jorgen as I said in the
beginning if these theories should then
we'll get a true bittersweet ending well
spend the last episode thinking Danny's
a terrible person this mad Queen watch
her get assassinated and feel everything
is justified watch John take the black
and go on the wall for killing her and
seeing brain star democratically chosen
as the new king of the Seven Kingdoms
then we find out that the Lord of Light
has been manipulating everything to get
to this exact moment where he bends the
arm to
wins the game of thrones that's why he
resurrected Jon Snow just to kill Danny
the sweet part will be when we learned
that Danny did not actually go mad and
did not play the part of brains puppet
brain Stark is the ultimate villain the
fact that we have been strictly shown
how they any obviously looks with anger
towards right keep answers saying not
towards the innocent might be a hint
that she did not actually burn the
capital and the innocent herself then if
laserdragon towards the red cape to kill
sir st. then just as we saw brains
vision of a share of a general flying
above King's Landing the joke on all the
sudden changes his direction and starts
burning down the innocent I think it was
made clear that Danny was heading
towards the Red Keep and never intended
to burn King's Landing
I believe it's brain who worked it or
dragon change the course em burn
everything and everyone the moment
before Joe Gunn goes mad we see the same
scene of his shadow over King's Landing
displayed so frequently brans visions
and that the showrunner said is the most
important vision of brain in his journey
I believe brains go much like with the
Mad King was to make Danny go mad and
become this mad queen who would burn
everything but he felt again this time
not because someone killed the mad
tyrant but because then he chose to be
good chose not to burn down the innocent
and that same brain worked into her
dragon and did it instead of her it will
explain why they don't cut Danny at all
after Jorgen starts burning King's
Landing if the head we would have seen
Danny freaking out about not being able
to control him
I truly believe Danny's not math queen
and she did not burn down the Capitol
and all the innocent brain started and
we learn it after seeing Jon killing
this mad queen Danny after Jon takes the
black and after brain stark is chosen as
the new king I firmly believe this is
the bittersweet ending we'll get met
Danny and Jon killing her is
straightforward there's a final huge
twist coming for sure and I believe this
is it please let me know your thoughts
about all this in the comment section
down below and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace